from Paul Verhoeven
the director who's satirize corporatism
in the film where a robot cop shoots
crooks in the day satirized militarism
in the film where the beefcake troupe
kills aliens real cool and satirized
sexism in the movie where the strippers
hump fight their way to the top the king
of having his cake and eating it too
will satirize colonialism in the action
flick where the beefcake does some
humping then shoots the dicks off
everyone on Mars Total Recall the good
one strap in for a mind-bending trip to
the future that's going through a big
90s retro craze apparently and see a
prophetic vision of today's society
where people can afford a real vacation
the robots took our jerbs and going
outside will kill you but hey at least
we're not paying for oxygen these days
right then we'd really know we were in a
dystopia oh well if this is our future
at least I won't be the only one with a
third nip in the jacooz meet Douglas
Quaid a man who can't tell fantasy from
reality like some other quakes you may
know he's either a Mindwipe super spy
with the key to saving Mars in his brain
or a construction worker who married
Sharon Stone
so yes two equally unlikely options but
when Quaid dreams he dreams of being
Arnold at his peak making all the great
Arnold noises
dunking on foods after he kills them
consider that a divorce see if the party
rooster and packing some serious Heat
both kinds of heat have been feeding
this thing it's just a boner thrill as
this atlas in Wonderland runs from
gunfight to gunfight to gunfight to
gunfight to gunfight to gunfire where
he'll swoon over the lovely milena a
hooker with a heart of arrow we don't
really get to know her that well tussle
with this wife Laurie a highly skilled
crotch assassin
battle ko Hagan Mars governor who sent
quake to earth with a false identity
surrounded by actors waited for him to
discovery someone else assumed he'll go
to more searching for vengeance than
befriend a very particular cab driver
and earn the trust of the mutant
resistance leader or none of his evil
plan works frankly I'm amazed at work
and fight Richter a goon stuck in middle
management who in one day has to let way
to his wife get berated by his boss and
lose both of his arms yeesh I hope this
is all a dream and Ricker's to some guy
who spit and quit drinking a Chili's or
something
so strapped in for a modern classic
action film that influenced the matrix
with its red pills reality bending and
firefight with riot cops and a roomful
of pillars and influenced avatar with
this double agent who fights for the
colonized people falls in love with one
of them meets their psychic leader then
accidentally leaves the bad guys to the
rebels home base wow that is a lot of
avatar but no matter how influential it
was the discerning cinephile will
recognize it for what it is a total
ripoff of the greatest sci-fi film ever
made
Spaceballs
[Music]
starring Hank Azaria Molina wins
flawless victory nut job we will deal
with your rebel friends soon enough
Richter and Morty Trotter cackle of
Technodrome douchy main buzz forget
about it
who will drive and a parent a spare Mars
hard in the future we have driverless
cars but they still talk to you this is
a dystopia hey screen junkies we're
pitting Pikachu against electro in an
all-new episode of power levels where
real scientists calculate the strongest
characters in TV and film so click the
box on the left to watch Jamie Foxx
fight a Pokemon just as the prophecies
foretold it's time to nut up or shut up